Even though I walk through the valley of the shadow
of death, I will not fear for you are with me.
You are my light and my salvation.
You restore me and lead me for your glory.
I long to dwell in your house forever.
What a blessing it is to be together.
Good morning again, church, family. My name is John.
If I haven't met you yet, I'd love to meet you sometime.
Um, one of the pastors here, uh, we would just be encouraged
to know that you came,
and so please let us know that also, if you've been here
for 60 years, we're encouraged that you came as well.
So thank you for that.
We do love everyone, uh, as we worship together.
Now, one of the hardest things
for me growing up was learning this concept of patience.
Uh, we live in this culture of immediate gratification
and it's hard to learn to wait.
Even our world, our flesh itself perpetuates this idea.
We hate waiting on anything, right?
Uh, we have microwave dinners.
We can't wait on it to be cooked.
We spend hundreds of dollars
to skip the line at Disney World, right?
Uh, we even will buy a new phone just to shave
microseconds off of the browser loading time
that we can't wait any longer.
Like it's amazing. I I was just thinking
about this with my phone here.
I amazing how
I can get frustrated when it buffers at all
when I'm watching a movie streaming
to my phone in the middle of nowhere, right?
Like how, when, when computers used to sound like this,
Okay. Right.
Okay. All right. I think we've had enough of that.
All that's some trauma from that, I think.
But, but that you, you remember that, right?
And you had to wait and wait
and then it was like 45 minutes to download.
Anyway, so we were so spoiled.
But here's what that culture of like faster and quicker
and now can do to us.
It can deeply affect our relationship with God
Because I know how hard it is for me like to stop
and to slow down enough to just enjoy God
and to to be in his word and to read
and to pray and meditate.
It can be hard because we're so driven towards speed.
There's always the pull of, of whatever game or episode
or movie or whatever else video we can have
that we feel is way more entertaining.
In fact, studies show it's rewiring our brains
because of how we have this speed in our lives,
but it also affects our relationship
with God in in another way.
We can easily get really frustrated with God
whenever things don't turn out quickly enough the way we
think they should when problems
and struggles don't seem to resolve quickly,
like we have to sit with
that pain longer than we think we should,
or we don't see justice coming as swiftly
as we think it should,
or we're waiting on a spouse
or waiting on a baby.
And so similar to last week, today in Psalm 70,
we're gonna see King David be very honest
about his struggle with having to wait on God,
waiting on God to come through for him in his time of need.
But we'll also be challenged with
what our response should be, even in the midst
of the temptation towards impatience.
What should we do? How should we respond?
And so let's ask God for help towards that right now.
Lord, we need you to teach us,
show us, change us.
We need you, holy Spirit, to speak through your word
directly to the corners of our hearts
that we might have neglected
or might have hidden to
show us what you want us to see today
and how to live in light of it
for your glory in light of grace.
Thank you. God help us in Jesus' name. Amen.
And so look with me now at Psalm 70.
This is the next Psalm, our series picking up in order.
Psalm 70 will again show us David's heart.
Look at it here heading
to this choir, master of David.
We know he wrote it then for the memorial offering.
Verse one, make haste, oh God, to deliver me, oh Lord,
make haste to help me.
Let them be put to shame and confusion who seek my life.
Let them be turned back
and brought to dishonor who delight in my hurt.
Let them turn back because of their shame.
Who say, aha, aha.
May all who seek you rejoice and be glad in you.
May those who love your salvation say evermore.
God is great,
but I am poor and needy.
Hastened to me, oh God, you are my help
and my deliverer, oh Lord, do not delay.
So this psalm is, is nearly a replica
of a portion of Psalm 40.
David wrote that as well.
There's a bit of modification here and there and
and you noticed in the super prescription
that says something about a memorial offering a memorial,
and it's like a word that means remembrance.
So in other words, what David did here, probably both
for himself but also for others, was to remind himself
and others of these truths that he had already written
and that he needed to remember in this moment.
And he wanted everybody to sing this
so they could remember these kind of things as well.
That who God is, what he said he is.
All of that's true no matter what you're facing.
So it's a memorial.
And notice there's a couple things here we can learn about
God from this psalm.
First, he said it very clearly
that God is our help and our deliverer.
That's the truths that he's wanting
to remind himself and others about.
God is our help and our deliverer.
He said it directly there at the end of verse five,
but if you notice, it was also in verse one, right?
Make haste, oh God, to deliver me.
Oh Lord, make haste to help me. Now we don't use that word.
Make haste very often. It means hurry up, don't delay.
Go quickly. He said it at the end of verse five.
Again, Yahweh do not delay even the second line
of verse five, he says, make haste hasten to me.
Oh God. So he's,
he's saying this thing like, this is urgent.
God, He said it so many times,
there's an urgency in his life and his heart.
These enemies are pressing in really closely.
They may be even at his doorstep
and he says, God, you, you better hurry up here.
I need you to hurry yet again.
Don't forget that he viewed Yahweh as his help
and his deliverer.
Now it's easy to believe that phrase
that God is our help and our deliverer.
He it. It's easy to remember
that when things are going really well in life, like
whenever they interview the guy who scored the,
the winning touchdown after the game, uh,
and he says, man, God came through for us.
Right? It's easy to say that when you actually win,
it's a lot harder, a lot more rare when someone says that
after they missed the winning shot, right?
And God came through for me today like, no, you don't.
You don't hear that one. That's again why I love the
Psalms, because they're honest.
We see it here in David that he viewed God as his help
and his deliverer even when he was
needy, right?
This is so clear right here that even when he was needy,
he still saw God as his help and his deliverer.
Verse five says, but I am poor
and needy hasten to me, oh God, you are my help.
My deliverer, oh Lord, do not delay.
Now, we don't know when David wrote this psalm, it,
it could have been when he was banished from Israel,
hunted like an animal by those
who were aligned with his son.
That could have been very true about his life at this point
where he was living in caves, he was on the run,
he was eating what he could scrounge up from the world like
he would have been needy at that moment.
He wouldn't have written this when he was rich in the
in the palace, all like he would.
This is when he was needy.
And so what he does here is he acknowledges it.
He said, I am poor and needy.
And it was in that state that he turned to the Lord
as his help and his deliver her.
Listen, it's okay
to acknowledge our neediness before the Lord.
In fact, it's okay to acknowledge it before other people
because it's true of all of us all the time.
We're always needy, but, but it's okay to do that.
It's only our pride that keeps us from doing that.
But we can and we should carry our needs to the Lord,
especially first because he already knows what they are.
You're not informing him of something,
reminding him, notifying him.
You're not informing him. He already knows.
And because he is the one who provides what you need,
Just listen to what Jesus had to say about neediness.
Matthew six.
He says, therefore I tell you,
do not be anxious about your life, what you will eat
or what you will drink, nor about your body.
What you'll put on is not life more than food
and the body more than clothing.
I mean, look at the birds of the air.
They neither sow nor reap nor gather into barns.
And yet your heavenly Father feeds them.
Are you not of more value than they?
And which of you by being anxious can add a single hour
to his span of life?
Why are you anxious about clothing?
Consider the lilies of the field, how they grow.
They need their toil nor spin.
Yet I tell you, even Solomon in all his glory was not
arrayed like one of these.
But if God so closed the grass in the field,
which today is alive, tomorrow's thrown into the oven,
will he not much more clothe you?
Oh, you have little faith. Therefore,
do not be anxious saying, what shall we eat?
What shall we drink? What shall we wear for the Gentiles?
Seek after all these things.
Now, here it is, and your heavenly Father knows
that you need them all, But seek first the kingdom of God
and his righteousness
and all these things will be added to you.
Now, notice something about that.
He never said he would provide all that you want,
but he does promise that he will give us everything we need.
Meaning, as you acknowledge your need,
he provides your need for you.
See, we can trust that God is our help
and our deliverer, even when we are needy
because we know his character and
because like Second Corinthians 12 says, when we are weak,
we're actually strong because it's his strength providing
For us.
We don't have to stay strong.
We don't have to act like we're strong.
We can be weak because he's strong for us.
So we can call on the Lord as our help
and our deliver even when we're
needy, which is all the time.
But also, there's a second piece here.
Even when we are hurt
and we learn from David that we call on him as our help
and our deliverer, even when we're hurt,
we see it in David's cry.
Let's look at verses two and three again.
He says, let them be put to shame
and confusion who seek my life, let them be turned back
and brought to dishonor who delight in my hurt.
Let them turn back because of their shame. Who say, aha.
Aha. So whatever the situation was,
we know David had been extremely hurt by these people.
Like they were literally trying to kill him.
They were taking joy in his pain and
and they said, aha, aha to him.
Now I'm not talking about that nasty
drink you get at Target.
Okay? Like that's, that's not what this is referring to,
which by the way, I'm an equal opportunity offender on that.
I don't like any of the spark.
So don't think I'm just picking on this one, But
that was some, for some reason my
mind went to that for the first one.
I read this. But what that word in Hebrew means, aha.
It's like a gotcha moment.
It's like a, a mocking false accusation.
I'm just delighting in your pain.
That's what that word means.
Now, don't you think David would've been deeply wounded
by people who were doing these kind of things to him?
Of course, like if not, he wouldn't be human.
Because this is part of our normal experience in life
that when we see people try to take our life,
they laugh at our pain, they mock us.
That's gonna hurt a little bit, right?
In fact, it might hurt a lot,
yet still in his pain
as he's being hurt.
Where did David turn?
He turned to his God, he turned to Yahweh
to the one that he saw as his help, as his deliverer.
He said, God, you are still that.
Do you think David was angry?
I'm sure he was at this point
because he's probably righteously angry.
These people weren't just attacking him,
they were opposing God.
So he's probably feeling this angst and some anger in it,
but still he took it to the Lord.
He left it in God's hands. He didn't try to take revenge.
He didn't try to take matters into his own hands.
He said, what does he say?
God, you deliver me God, you help me.
You bring confusion in their minds. I can't do that.
God, you turn them back in dishonor. I can't do that.
Only you, God are my help
and my delivery is
that my perspective when I'm hurt,
like do I immediately and fully take it to the Lord?
Or do I try to be my own, help my own deliverer?
A lot of the things we do in our lives when we're hurt,
we might claim that we're bringing justice.
But I'm afraid that most of the things
that we do come from a heart of vengeance,
not from true righteous, ju justice.
There's actually a powerful scene in David's life.
It's in one Samuel 24.
We're gonna start studying one Samuel this fall, but
but the first king Saul, he was jealous
of God's next king David,
and he was hunting David in the
wilderness to try to kill him.
Well, it just so happened that one day David
and his men were hiding very deep in a cave, and Saul
and his men entered that cave to get out of the sun's heat.
They didn't go as far back as David and his men were,
but they were in this same cave.
And I want you to listen to how this plays out.
Keeping in mind what we just read in Psalm 70,
this is one Samuel 24.
It says, now, David and his men were sitting in the
innermost parts of the cave.
And the men of David said to himHe, is the day
of which the Lord said to you, behold,
I'll give your enemy into your hand.
You shall do to him as it shall seem good to you.
And David arose
and stealthily cut off a corner of Saul's robe.
And afterward David's heart struck him
because he cut off a corner of Saul's robe And he said
to his men, the Lord forbid
that I should do this thing to my Lord.
The Lord's anointed to put out my hand against him,
seeing he is the Lord's anointed.
Like David felt so guilty.
And so David persuaded his men with these words,
did not permit them to attack Saul.
Saul rose up and left the cave and went on his way.
And afterward David also arose
and went outta the cave, called
after Saul, my Lord the king.
And when Saul looked back behind him, David bowed
with his face to the earth and paid homage.
And David said to Saul, Hey, hey Saul.
Why do you listen to the words of men who say, behold,
David seeks your harm.
Behold, this day, your eyes have seen
how the Lord gave you today into my hand in the cave.
Some told me to kill you, but I spared you.
I said, I will not put out my hand against the Lord
for he is the Lord's anointed.
See my Father, see the corner of your robe in my hands for
by the fact that I cut off the corner
of your robe did not kill you.
You may know and see that there's no wrong
or treason in my hands.
I've not sinned against you,
though you hunt my life to take it.
May the Lord judge between me and you.
May the Lord avenge me against you,
but my hand shall not be against you.
May the Lord therefore be judged
and give sentence between me and you and see to it
and plead my cause and deliver me from your hand.
You see that
David was hunted by Saul.
An army of 3000 men were coming
after him to try to kill him.
He was sent away from the city living on the run.
And what did he do? David trusted God.
He trusted God. He said to Saul,
it's the Lord's job to judge between us.
It's the Lord's job to bring vengeance.
It's not my job to take you out, Saul. That's God's work.
It's not my job to do that.
He had a heart absent of vengeance against this man
who was trying to kill him.
Listen, it takes a mature trust to leave
your hurt in God's hands
to release your grip on it and and to give it to him.
But if you see God as your help
and your deliverer, that's how you can do that.
David knew God's gonna take care of this. God's got this.
I know I can release
this, but here's the problem.
That sounds easy. Of course we can do that.
The problem comes whenever
that resolution takes longer than we think it should.
That's why the third aspect of Psalm 70 is
that God is still our help
and our deliverer, even when he seems delayed.
We learned that from David in Psalm 70.
Even when God seems delayed,
he is our help and our deliverer.
Remember how urgent David felt? Make haste. Hurry up.
God, they're right here. I need you now.
But it also felt to 'em that God was delayed,
that somehow God was not gonna come through for him.
Listen, maybe that's where you're at right now.
Maybe you see it in your own life
wondering if God's gonna resolve this
or maybe see it in your kids' lives
or you see it in your friends
and like God, when when are you gonna come through for them?
You see these struggles and it feels like God is absent
because that's really what it feels like, doesn't it?
It it, it feels like somehow God has clocked out of his job
and he's moved on and he's just said, I'm, I'm done.
Eight to five, I'm done. Right?
And he's not even part of it anymore.
And it feels like everything is out
of control it feels like.
Is that true though?
Now theologically, we know that's not true,
but experientially it can certainly feel that way, can it?
This is how Psalm 44 says it awake,
why are you sleeping?
Oh Lord, rouse yourself. Do not reject us forever.
Why do you hide your face?
Why do you forget our affliction and our oppression?
Like can't it feel like God's asleep at the wheel
or that he's hiding himself from us
or that he's even worse forgotten us?
You look around at your life, the world is like God,
I'm questioning whether you're even real.
That's why we have to come back to the truths
of God's character in His word, reminding us
who he is, what he's done.
This is why we come back to it.
We come back to what we've seen in the Old Testament already
in Psalm 23, this famous Psalm that David wrote says this,
the Lord is my shepherd.
I shall not want. He makes me lie down in green pastures.
He leads me beside still waters. He restores my soul.
He leads me in passive righteousness for his namesake.
Even though I walk through the valley of the shadow
of death, I will fear no evil, for you are with me.
Your rod, your staff, they comfort me.
You prepare a table before me in the presence of my enemies,
you anoint my head with oil.
You my cup overflows.
Surely goodness and mercy shall follow me all the days
of my life and I shall dwell in the house
of the Lord forever.
Listen, if it feels like you're walking through the valley
of the shadow of death, right?
Those those are all dark language words
and it feels like you're absent from God,
it feels like he's gone from you.
Listen, remember, if you are one of his sheep, then he is
with you in the middle of all of it.
Even if it seems like the darkness is lasting too long.
If you are his sheep, he is your shepherd.
And he never abandons his sheep.
We've gotta go back to the promises
of his character in Psalm 23.
Even in Hebrews 13, verse five says,
I will never leave you nor forsake you.
He's not saying like, I'll leave you
and forsake you at certain times.
Right? I will never.
And when God says, I will never do
something, he will never do that.
Not like you and me we're wishy-washy.
He will never abandon his people.
So again, even though it might feel like he is delayed,
I heard it said this way, God is never late
and he's rarely early.
He is always exactly right on time, his time.
So the Lord is our help
and our deliver, even when we're needy, even when it hurts,
even when it feels like he's delayed,
he is our help and our deliverer.
That's a glorious truth.
Just to hang onto and to remind yourself
and remind ourselves about,
there's actually more here in Psalm 70 about who God is.
When you look at Psalm 70,
you look at verse four especially,
and you see something else.
You see that he is also our glory and our joy.
He's our help and our deliverer. We saw that in verse five.
Verse four says, he is our glory and our joy.
Look again in verse four, he says, may all
who seek you rejoice
and be glad in you May those
who love your salvation say evermore.
God is great.
He is our joy, the one who makes us glad,
and he is our glory, the one who's worthy of us proclaiming
and displaying how great our God really is.
This is our joy and our glory,
and we want those things, don't we?
Like I could poll every Christian I've ever met,
like we can walk around
and talk to every Christian here anywhere else, and
and we could ask them three questions.
Do you want joy in God?
Do you want to be glad in God?
And and do you want to give glory to God?
Universally yes to all of those, right?
Like we want joy. We want to be glad in God.
We want to give glory to God.
That's part of being a Christian.
But did you notice something about those
questions here in verse four
I, There were actually some conditions
on getting those results, getting those outcomes
that we want.
May all who seek you rejoice and be glad in you.
May those who love your salvation say evermore.
God is great. So here's a
couple questions I want to
Ask Myself and us if we want those outcomes.
A couple questions. Get us there.
First, do we seek his presence?
Do we seek
His presence?
I mean, what did David say?
May all who seek you
Rejoice and be glad in you.
And so David knew that it was possible to have joy
and gladness in God's presence,
but he also knew that we have to seek the Lord to secure
that joy and gladness.
So do we. Do we seek
an intimate relationship with him or,
or do we instead just lament that we never feel close
to him, that he feels absent from us?
Now, let me be clear. There are times we know
that the Lord allows us to go through dark nights
of the soul through storms in our lives,
even when we're seeking him, even when we're following Him.
Yes, that happens. And
there's also truth that sometimes our sin in our self
hides God from us.
He didn't go anywhere, but we walked away, right?
So there's, so there's, there's parts of this that yes,
we're gonna feel some of those realities,
but often, often we don't
feel close to him because we're not really pursuing him.
That we treat God more like an accessory
to our lives rather than the core of our lives
that we're so distracted
and we're more entertained by work
or money or brawl stars or TikTok
or whatever other things that we do, relationships,
our bodies, we we're so distracted, so more entertained
by those kind of things.
And I wonder why I feel so dry at
Times.
Like I wonder why he feels far away at times.
I wonder why I feel a lack of joy and gladness in him at
Times.
I wonder why my needs overwhelm me,
why my hurts consume me while my,
while my doubts rage against me.
And I, I, I wonder about all those things I'm questioning,
probably because I've sought my joy
and my gladness in everything else
But him.
May all who seek you rejoice and be glad
In you.
And listen, even if that Spurgeon said this,
even if it starts in the darkness,
Hebrews 11 says that he rewards those who seek him.
Light will come maybe not soon,
but light will come even in the darkness.
But here's the reality of that.
In some ways, that first question
is dependent on the second question, do we seek him?
Do we seek his presence?
Well, in some ways it's dependent
again, directly from verse four.
This second question, do we love his salvation?
Do we seek him for joy, for gladness in our lives?
But it kind of hinges on this one.
Do you love his salvation?
Now, David's talking about this immediate deliverance.
His enemies are pressing in,
and so he's like, God, I need you to get me outta here.
He would've rejoiced at that salvation.
But as great as that can be to be delivered from enemies
to be delivered from hard situations, there's also
the greater salvation that we can love eternally.
It's what we talk about every week here.
It's what we build our lives on.
It's the gospel, good news, where Jesus
lived the perfect law abiding life that we could not live
where Jesus faced.
You notice this in the, the story of the, the crucifixion.
Jesus faced the same kind
of ahas when he was crucified on the cross.
People mocking him, looking at him falsely accusing him,
that David felt in some ways,
Jesus faced those same things while dying
as our sin substitute on that cross.
And then he rose again on the third day to defeat sin
and death on that day that we couldn't do ourselves.
See, that then leads to anyone
who recognizes their sin against God, recognizes their need
for Jesus' work in their place.
What Jesus did means you can be saved from that sin.
That's how the wrath of God
that we deserve is transferred from them onto Christ.
And what Christ does is he transfers his
righteousness onto us.
So we stand righteous before God forever.
See, we call that the gospel, the good news.
That's actually great news, isn't it?
Do you love it? Do you
love his salvation?
If we do, if we truly love
his salvation, then what?
Verse four said here, he said,
then we will forever say something.
What did he say? You'll forevermore forever. Say what?
God is. Great Again.
Do we like, do we do?
We so deeply love the salvation
that Jesus offers us that I can't help
but declare everywhere I go that God is great.
His greatness in his sovereignty, his character,
his provision for me, his greatness in his work, in my place
for salvation, his great promises of eternity
with him forever and ever in the new heavens
and like the greatness of God
because of his salvation.
Do you love his salvation?
Maybe a better question is this.
Would those who know you best agree
that the thing you love the most is salvation?
Jesus, that's a little
harder question, isn't it?
Would those who know you best agree that that's
what you love the most in your life?
Or is it anything else?
If it is anything else, that is the very definition
of an idol,
but I hope we see it today, church, I hope I see it more.
I hope we see it more church, that there is nothing
more fulfilling.
There's nothing more satisfying.
There's nothing more thrilling than a close
intimate relationship with the God of the universe
through Jesus Christ.
Do you see how good he is
that he would never leave his children,
never forsake his people, never abandon us in any situation
that he would do all that he did to save us?
How great is our God?
So here's what we're gonna do. I wanna invite the worship
leaders to come back out now to help us lead toward exactly
what this passage just said we're supposed to do.
By the way, did you notice we were led first part
of this service by a choir?
What's the heading of verse 70 to the choir master, right?
What does it say to the choir master?
Well, David wrote this so that
the body could sing it together.
Now, this is not the only choir here today, right?
We are the choir, right?
Every week we are the choir singing the truths
of God's word.
That means we are to sing these things together.
Here's the interesting thing, uh, Joe said this
during the week, this, this to the choir master,
meaning it's corporate.
Look at all the I and me language throughout this.
Like he, he's saying, you all should sing this,
but use singular language, first person.
Like what that means simply is
that we are all in this together.
We can sing this together
because we're all in this together.
And so again, in light of his goodness
in salvation especially, here's what Psalm 30,
David wrote this as well.
Here's how it describes how our response should be.
You have turned for me, my mourning into dancing.
You have loosed my sackcloth, clothed me with gladness.
That my glory may sing your praise and not be silent.
Oh Lord, my God, I will give thanks to you forever.